As we increase n toward infinity, the number we have for A over here gets
closer and closer to a certain very special number. That number is e. But what
on earth is e? We haven't been using that letter to stand for anything. Well,
this is a very important point. e is actually a number, an irrational number to
be precise. And we can approximate it as 2.718281828459, and of course, this
decimal continues forever, since this number is irrational. It's a number that
has special significance for higher level mathematics, biology, chemistry and
many other fields. So it's really exciting that we're going to get to work with
it. Conveniently, scientific calculators also generally have buttons for e on
them. On my calculator, it's right here, and when I press it, well, it just
types the letter e. But if we press equals, then you see a rounded version of
this number. Now, remember, this is not the exact value of e, this is an
approximation.